so let me uh introduce our first talk of
the day this is uh from ross otto he uh
he's a
i think now a tenured professor at the
at the uh
department of psychology at mcgill
university in montreal
and uh he did uh
i guess he did his phd with bradley love
and
art markman in at ut austin and then did
some postdoctoral work with nathaniel
dahl and uh
uh i guess back when he was in nyu and
uh has been working a lot and in
cognitive effort and i think sort of
pushing that into sort of new domains
and uh today he's gonna talk to us about
some uh
some work on sort of uh social norms and
communication of social norms and uh
yeah i'll uh give you the floor ross
thanks for the intro so i'll try to keep
this brief i think people have
things they want to do so i actually
have to cut and run after my talk
um get back to montreal but um yeah so
this is work done by um shenzheng who
was a
visiting phd student um from beijing
normal who was in hung around my lab for
a year and did
a couple of really
cool experiments in my views so i can
tell you about them today um and this is
also in collaboration with sebastian
ettu
and orio feldenhall who i guess
has been around this conference
a bit
so
this title this talk is learning moral
values observing another's desire to
punish enhances one's own punitive
behavior that's a bit of a mouthful so
hopefully i can unpack this
um for you so i think many of us who
study kind of social type things right
or or morality
uh are familiar with the you know what
you call the ultimatum game right in the
in the general setup right is there's a
proposer
um who has some endowment right of of
points right or money think of these as
dollars right
and and basically proposes a split with
this other person called the receiver
so
um essentially right
up in among these 10 points right they
could elect to give some proportion of
them right to the receiver so so just
sort of more formally right the proposer
would keep 10 minus x right and the
receiver would get x so obviously
whatever the receiver
uh whatever the receiver gets right the
proposer doesn't get so there's kind of
um
the the reason this is kind of
interesting right is it it provides an
interesting kind of operation
operationalization right of of fairness
versus unfairness um
and so the way the ultimatum game works
in in the typical formulation is the
subject right in an experiment plays the
role of the receiver and so you get some
kind of offer right which can vary in
how fair it is right so
five and five would be your sort of
classic fair offer right there's there's
equality right or equity there if you
want
um and you have the decision to accept
it so you get what you were sort of
proposed to receive or you can reject it
and that means no one gets anything and
and the like one kind of idea right in
in um
you know people who study the ultimatum
game is that
rejection
is is bad in the sense that you get
nothing right you should at least
there's there's a sense in which you
should just take whatever you're offered
right yet people still reject unfair
offers and and that's sort of thought to
be a sort of punishment signal right to
the proposer saying
that was unfair now no one gets anything
um and there's a whole bunch of
interesting actually cross-cultural work
um on this like what type of cultures
are more likely to accept or reject
unfair offers um
so
of course right if you accept you get
the proposed amount right if you reject
no one gets anything
so the classic kind of inequity right
the classic kind of thing that that
we've seen
uh people reject right is what's called
disadvantageous inequity so
if you if someone proposes hey i'm gonna
keep eight bucks and give you two
that's that's disadvantageous in equity
right the receiver stands to get less
than the proposer and so
um there's a whole again this this is a
sort of classic case right of of looking
at rejection behavior
one thing that that oriole found in a
past paper that that we're sort of
basing this work on right is people seem
to be more likely to punish unfair
offers
on behalf of another receiver that is if
you're watching an interaction and you
get to make the call
whether the offer is accepted or
rejected
people will
often engage in more sort of punitive
behavior on behalf of another person
than on behalf of themselves
and that's that's kind of interesting
and kind of maybe sets the stage a
little bit or what we want to look at
here
um
and so and so one
in this kind of line of studies right
one question oriole and i had was can
people learn through exposure to others
preferences
to reject disadvantageously unfair
offers so
that is if to the extent right that
people tend to not reject unfair offers
right they don't punish unfair behavior
right maybe you can sort of teach them
to and and that could be a form of sort
of learning a norm right through say
vicarious learning right or you could
call it contagion
effects things like that so
the kind of idea right is observing the
expression of a moral norm that is
unfairness should be punished
might alter how people themselves value
punishment themselves that is
when they're later asked to make a
decision on their own behalf right will
they sort of what will that kind of
behavior they've observed kind of bleed
into or will it be contagious and sort
of be expressed in their own punishment
behavior so so the paradigm that that we
came up with
was um had these three phases so that
the baseline phase
um is essentially an ultimatum game with
different levels of unfairness and and
importantly the subject
in this experiment is deciding for the
self so you're just getting some offers
right of various levels of
fairness and unfairness um
and you're and you're sort of and we're
just asking okay what is this subject's
baseline punishment references
uh-huh
the proposer is so so we did this study
on mturk and we believe that these
subjects believed these proposers were
other
sort of random people on the internet um
but right it's all the deck was stacked
so that way we had
a nice range of unfair offers so so they
range from somewhat unfair right the 60
40 split right to very unfair
then the kind of interesting thing we
did here was we we had subjects then
assume the role of this third party
that's watching interactions
between a proposer and another receiver
so
in this phase right the subject decides
for the receiver that is is this offer
going to be punished or not that is is
this split going to be rejected or
accepted
and then the kind of interesting twist
was um the subject receives feedback
about what the receiver would have done
so in other words you sort of
you sort of meet out the punishment uh
right but but after that happens
this sort of fictitious receiver tells
you
um i would have liked to see that
rejected so in a sense right there's
this there's this there's this learning
of preferences that subjects could do
right where
if they want to
sort of bring their uh punishment
preferences in line with what the
receiver wants then they can sort of use
that information to incrementally
uh update their their punishment
preferences
and then and then in this transfer phase
it was the exact same thing as the
baseline phase the participant again
is the receiver and decides for
themselves so the question is does
exposure to this to sort of
strong preferences for punishment of
unfair behavior
sort of bleed into subjects own
preferences when they decide on their
own behalf so everyone gets this
all right great because this is the
whole
this is the whole um kind of
idea what we found briefly right is that
people increase their endorsement of the
punitive rejection option
um foregoing their own monetary
self-benefit right
um and what you see is that this
and this is pretty typical rejection
behavior so at baseline people were
around 27
uh their rejection rates around 27
after seeing these kind of clear
preferences on this other person's
behalf
right and doing the the punishment for
them
that there was a sort of contagion
effect where then subjects significantly
increase their punishment rates on
behalf of themselves so we we take this
as evidence for some kind of contagion
effect right or some kind of vicarious
learning where having to do this on
another person's behalf teaches you that
you should also be punishing
unfair offers even if if you stand to uh
be um
or rather if you stand to benefit or
even
get punished
so
um
so so the work that shen did that i want
to talk about today
expanded this a little bit and and so
one kind of interesting thing right is
is there's a couple different flavors of
inequity so what we studied but in this
original um original study with orielle
was
disadvantageous in equity right so all
of the
all of this sort of unfairness
was
in these offers right was based on you
getting less than the proposer but
there's another kind rate of
inequity and that's called advantageous
inequity and so that would be like if
the proposer said hey i'm gonna keep two
and give you eight
right so
um if you're like a guilt-prone person
or something you might say ah that's not
i don't like this split
um personally i would accept all of
these but
the idea right is people don't tend to
reject these it's very it's very
difficult to kind of observe situations
where people will say no i don't want
that i'm going to reject this and and
and no one gets anything because this is
unfair it's a very high-minded kind of
unfairness
um and so and so one question i guess
the key question shen wanted to ask in
the study was
can aversion to advantageous inequity be
taught similarly as we did for the
through um as we did similarly right
with exposure to
disadvantageous inequity preferences in
the previous study
um so so that's so that's the idea so
how can we get people to to learn this
and so we we expanded this paradigm a
little bit
right and there was the idea was in
there there was two between subject
conditions
and in these conditions
subjects see one of
um
one of two types of model receivers in
the learning phase so
in the control condition we we sought to
replicate um our previous study and so
and so it's helpful to visualize it this
way so these are
agents right that subjects are exposed
to in the learning phase
and and here's their sort of policy
right in terms of what
types of offers
they what what their probability of
endorsing rejection of unfair or fair
offers is right and so in this control
condition what you see is that okay this
is the disadvantageous inequity side
right everything to the left of 50 50.
this in this condition right that the
receiver that you experience in the
learning phase right only wants
punishment for
disadvantageous inequity so this is in a
sense like a conceptual replication
of our earlier study um so it's it's
helpful to
establish that they'll learn that right
again in this other setting more
interestingly we came with this what we
call the punishment condition and this
is a receiver a model receiver that
punishes both types
of inequity so
an extremely
advantageously unfair offer like a 1090
this model receiver would be most likely
to reject that right so there's kind of
symmetric
uh reference here if you if you will
um
and so again right it was it was very
the setup was very similar here so in
this baseline phase we're just
collecting um collecting sort of
subjects baseline rates of rejection
right for different types of offers
stemming from
disadvantageously
unfair to advantageously unfair
and then and then we added um this kind
of phase right where they obviously also
rate the fairness of the offer they just
saw and so that might give us a kind of
window right on
what subjects think is going on with
these offers
um and then in the learning phase um
essentially what we did was the
participant again decides for the
receiver
and then they see what they would have
preferred
so so here's an example so you see this
person we hope subjects believe is a
real person
on the internet um they see an unfair
offer get made and then they decide
whether it should be accepted or
rejected right and then they see this
feedback
player b would have accepted that right
so that's sort of positive feedback in a
kind of reinforcement learning
like framework
and again this is just another way of
view this is just what these punishment
rates look like in the two conditions
right so the model
the model receiver was either in this
control condition that only punishes or
prefers rejection of disadvantageous
inequity
where in the punishment condition they
have this kind of symmetric thing where
they punish they want to see punishment
of both types
um
and so again then we had a transfer
phase uh identical to the baseline phase
so we could observe the kind of shift
in preferences right on on in terms of
punishment on behalf of the subject
um okay so
the kind of key question right is
departure participants learn to punish
unfair offers right measured by the
difference between the baseline and
transfer phase
on the basis of learning about others
fairness preferences in the learning
phase um
so
what we found right was in this
conceptually replicates our previous
study right is that okay here's the um
it's plotted a little bit um differently
here here are the baseline rejection
rates and here the transfer rejection
rates right and so if you see this go up
it means subjects started punishing more
right and these are disadvantageously
unequal offers so what we see is in both
conditions right this control condition
the punishment condition you see an
increase in punishment rates and again
right they receive both conditions right
receive the same kind of feedback
from this from this model kind of
receiver right so we wouldn't expect
these to differ between themselves but
what we would between the conditions but
what we would expect right is that their
punishment rates should go up for these
offer types um
importantly right this is kind of a
useful sanity check we look at fair 50
50 offers right there's no punishment
of those
right that makes sense everyone's happy
um and and you shouldn't we shouldn't
see much change in that either right
people don't start becoming mad about
equality for some reason
midway through the experiment and then
and then what we see right in in the
other uh in the advantageously unequal
conditions right is that in the
punishment condition where subjects had
exposure to
uh to an uh a model receiver
that strongly disprefers advantageous
inequity
we see an increase in these rejection
rates for these advantageously unfair
offers so i think these effects are
weaker than than the on the dia side
right at the same time a whole bunch of
literature suggests people
rarely do this right and it's a kind of
puzzle about how do we get
people to do this more we want to live
in a more equal world so
um
the other kind of important thing here
right is you didn't see this lift in the
control condition
which makes sense right because subjects
never learned those kinds of preferences
right in um in the learning phase right
those model players they saw
did not have preferences for punishment
of these offer types
um so that that's um so that's
interesting i think
um we could also get fairness ratings
right so um after these different types
of offers right when subjects chose on
their own behalf
um they were asked to say how unfair was
this proposal in general
um and so one another thing we'd ask is
was their learning
as evidenced by these fairness ratings
right which would suggest that they're
doing it
uh they're doing their change in
punishment behavior right has something
to do with their perception that these
offers are unfair
and so so here these fairness ratings
plotted the same way so so lower means
more unfair right or higher means more
fair
these kind of move down over time
um not not um
not not a whole bunch i think the idea
is that in disadvantageous inequality
subjects already kind of believe
these are unfair
what we do see is this kind of change
right in the punishment condition um
in fairness ratings right so they
start to learn
i think this data suggests that these
sort of advantageously unequal offers
are also unfair right so so the the sort
of change in ratings mirrors the change
in in punishment preferences
um so so we think that's interesting
um
right same slide here the other thing we
could look at right and this is where
this connects to rl a little bit more is
learning phase behavior right so you can
so so subject's got many many trials
right of different offer types
um
on behalf of this kind of model player
right and so
if we look at these kind of learning
curves right like rejection rates over
time
what we could ask is okay does the
learning phase behavior suggest learn
these suggest that subjects learn these
preferences in a kind of incremental
trial by trial fashion
so here are the learning curves for the
control condition right and what you see
is in in these uh punishment um sorry in
these offer types for which punishment
rate was was strongly um
reinforced right by the um by virtue of
the receiver's stated preferences right
you see that the rejection rates go up
over time um
importantly right there's nothing to
really learn
um in
the um in for example the fair offers
right or the advantageously on equal
offers right because there was no sort
of systematic reinforcement given
uh for these um
for rejecting these offers
oh sorry yeah this is this figure could
be could be better so these are
these all these offer types in the
learning phase were sort of interleaved
and so what we're doing is we're just
saying okay
let's just look at for example these
highly unfair offers and what and what
the kind of change in rejection behavior
over time is does that help answer your
question
okay and then and then what we see right
and and this is expected right
is that in the advantageous inequality
or sorry in the punishment condition
right we start seeing these learning
curves emerge
um for punishment of advantageously
unequal offers right and and that's to
be expected right in the sense that
these were the ones that were reinforced
so i think this is again a kind of nice
sanity check right
these people in the control condition
shouldn't be learning anything whereas
you should see some kind of signs of
learning in the punishment
condition
um
just really briefly what one kind of
intuition we had was that
learning phase behavior that is just
changes between the beginning and the
end of the learning phase
might have some predictive bearing right
on um contagion that is the difference
in preferences
in the baseline and transfer phase right
when subjects were deciding on their own
behalf um what we see is in most
conditions in the kind of expected
places there's a predictive relationship
between
learning phase behavioral change and
this sort of index of contagion um
vis-a-vis the transfer scores
um
and so
another thing shed wanted to do
was um
we if we have this kind of
behavior right um that looks like
incremental learning this sort of thing
right
is is amenable to sort of trial by trial
models of learning and maybe you can see
where this is going because this is an
rl meeting
um one thing we do right is is is ask
okay maybe we could construct some
different types of models which make
different assumptions about how these
preferences are learned
and then and then and then maybe this
these kind of model fits would tell us
something interesting right about what
this what sort of learning is
underpinning
um at least learning phase behavior
so so one candidate model right is just
simple kind of vanilla rl as we call it
so
what this model is doing right is just
learning a simple policy mapping
different offer types
to actions right so
what what this policy would sort of
learn right is that okay if i get this
moderately unfair
offer
um i'm most likely to reject it right so
you could think of this as just a kind
of table of q values right mapping where
there's q values for different offer
types right and those values are learned
on the basis of the
receiver's feedback
and so that's the kind of that's the
kind of
i guess most simplistic
possible like account of this
um but but
it stands to reason right that subjects
might be doing something more
sophisticated and actually
making some inferences about what what
is the receiver like as a as a person if
you will and so
um
there's a a fairly well-known kind of
simple model of
unfairness or utility um of fairness
but the fair schmidt
model um so it's been it's always weird
to me that that the person best known
for studying fairness is named fair
uh
if you need a panel topic you go with
that so that
the idea with the the classic fair
schmidt um inequity uh function is that
receivers preferences right are governed
by utility function and so and so in
fair schmidt and this is the kind of
classic formulation
the utility right of accepting an offer
is kind of modulated by these two
parameters right um so so you have the
offer content here but then you have
these two parameters right that govern
um how much disutility you get from two
the two different kinds of inequity so
so your alpha parameter here you can
call the nv parameter right that sort of
scales or or weights how much
disadvantages in equity contributes to
the disutility of this offer and of
course the presumption is that something
that has a lot of
disutility will be unlikely to be chosen
right by
um
an agent an agent using these kind of
fair schmidt
uh preferences
the um and then you have this beta
parameter which we call guilt that's
this parameter that that kind of weights
the um contribution of advantages and
equity right so
to the extent that you don't like
getting more than other people
right a larger beta a larger beta
parameter will sort of characterize
how much
you don't like that how much that
contributes to the overall disutility of
the offer
um and so and so just you know just some
simplifying assumptions here right we
assume the disk utility
or rather the utility of of rejecting an
offer is always zero right because you
get nothing so the real question is how
bad does it make you feel
what what the fair schmitt utility
function kind of says is how bad does it
make you feel to accept this offer right
and if if um if it turns out that this
is less than zero right then you would
predict right a fair schmidt govern
agent should reject the offer
um so so the sort of simplest
formulation of this we call the static
fair schmidt model so essentially
there's what what what we're trying to
fit as free parameters is the alpha and
the beta parameter for the model player
of course it would be weird to assume
this was static right if what subjects
are doing the learning phase is trying
to learn the preferences or the
preference of the utilities
governing the preferences of the model
player so
um
shen developed this model we call the
fair schmidt inference model
i won't go into the details here because
it's just a lot of boring equations but
i'm happy to
send you a paper or something
what we do is we assume the subject
infers the parameters of the fair
schmitt utility function so again
what the player is doing in the learning
phase is figuring out what alpha is and
what beta is for this model player and
then you can use those to it can use
those right to essentially inform
choices to reject or accept offers
because you want to make the model
player
happy you want to reduce um their
disutility
so
um doing it doing kind of model
comparison and penalizing for um
complexity with the aic
what we find
perhaps and surprisingly is the fair
schmidt inference model uh best fit the
learning phase behavior so lower scores
are better here
what we see here is um actually the rl
model that that's just learning this
simple mapping of offer types to
rejection rates is doing a terrible job
of accounting for the choice behavior in
comparison to for example to this
these two fair schmitt models so the
static model
importantly a bit worse than the
inference model which would make sense
right if what we're saying is subjects
are not only assuming this preference
function but learning the parameters
governing it um so just one kind of
interesting thing this this um bear
schmidt inference model lets you do is
look under the hood and say okay what
would we assume in the course of uh the
learning phase subjects would be
learning about
um envy and guilt so these alpha and
beta parameters
and what we see right this is just
simulating the model
based on the
the
best fit parameters is that
over time right at least in the
punishment condition the model would
predict that
um this guilt parameter is increasing
that is in order to account right or in
order to explain the model players
preferences right there must be some
kind of in uh
aversion right or disutility to
advantageous inequity and so that has to
go up over time right to kind of explain
the model player's behavior um
so so right that's the
that's the um the first experiment the
second experiment was just a subtle kind
of twist
um
on the first
so
we have this model um comparison result
right that suggests that subjects are
doing something akin to inferring
the preferences of the model player
right they're not just learning this in
a kind of stimulus response
simple rl like way
and so if that's true right if subjects
are indeed learning these latent
preferences of the receiver
we would expect that um
feedback
feedback driven learning right of the of
the target right or the receiver's
punishment preferences should generalize
right across offer types so the
intuition here right is if we only
reinforce
one uh
uh offered if we only reinforce one
offer type here that is
if only the 30 70
uh offers rate which are advantageously
unequal
um are reinforced right with punishment
preferences
we should see that subjects should
generalize this to other similar
contexts that is in this high in the
case of this highly unfair offer right
if what the if what the um subject did
was actually infer some kind of
underlying preference function then it
should be easy to also
infer right that oh i also want to
reject 1090 offers right and importantly
no feedback was given for these so this
is a kind of stringent test
right of generalization
um so and and i think that the kind of
second order question here is does this
learning
um
what does this learning in turn transfer
to participants own
fairness preferences right again through
this kind of contagion um this kind of
contagion measure
um and importantly right
um this is really brief right
what we find is okay we we replicate the
sort of standard stuff we find with
learning um to punish disadvantageous um
inequity
what we see here is that
there's there's a positive kind of um
there's a positive change right in
rejection rates
for these um highly unfair um
advantageously unequal offers right
where no training was given right so
subjects never saw
that they should be rejecting 1090
offers but on the basis of only learning
about these
um less unfair offers right they're sort
of generalizing and saying okay now i
get the idea like unfairness is bad so i
should be more likely to reject
he's highly unfair um di offers so i
think that's a nice kind of um it's a
nice kind of follow-up test right
suggesting that they are learning
something about an underlying uh
preference function
um so that's
so that's it so so um
in conclusion right i think what we've
we've demonstrated
is that uh exposure to individuals who
strongly prefer punishment of both
disadvantageous and advantageous
inequality
resulted in a boost of social norm
enforcement behaviors and this was made
on the subject's own behalf
um
and so um there's this uh
there's this kind of idea right that
rejecting these unequal offers right
could be a social signal right like a
form of norm enforcement like hey i'm
going to punish both of us to make sure
you don't propose something this unfair
again
um and i think um i hope i've
demonstrated that
the acquisition of others preferences is
seems to be contingent right on on
something on incremental learning from
social feedback
and looks like it's dependent on
mechanisms akin to those um deployed in
this kind of trial and error learning um
this shouldn't say basic rl because that
was the worst model but
you get the idea so uh
i think we have some time for questions
here before i have to go so thanks to
shen for
doing all the work and my collaborators
orion sebastian
[Applause]
thanks ross that was awesome um
any questions eugene
thank you thank you for the talk that
was great um i was wondering if you in
the disadvantaged inequity case you can
make the curves go the other way
by uh
inducing them to accept more often they
reject and whether you've looked into it
or thought about that no we haven't
thought about that that would be kind of
interesting so so because it's it's in a
sense like selfish
um where you can kind of struggle with
like like a sort of argument right that
maybe it would be even more high-minded
to just accept things that are unfair
for you that'd be cool follow-up and i
think i think
like within this paradigm like that
would be a sort of simple change today
so yeah
thanks
thank you for the talk
hey uh thanks for that really
interesting stuff um
towards the end where you showed that
like
if
the 30-70 split or 70 30 split uh
were considered to be rejected then
you could show kind of a zero shot
transfer to the 90 10.
um
did you guys consider like
that kind of assumes that the agent like
player b is kind of acting rationally
and that like they wouldn't just all of
a sudden
accept a 90 10 if they were rejecting 70
30 but they could
i guess kind of it wouldn't make sense
in this context but be acting
strategically to
try and make player a
uh
maybe change their policy
so
have you thought about like what would
happen or would there be any surprise
on behalf of the human if
player b
kind of didn't
act very sensically like that
oh like if they were inconsistent or
something if they were inconsistent yeah
and then also like they would reject 70
30 but then
accept 90 10.
oh that'd be interesting so what
to try and influence
what player a's policy was
yeah that would be kind of interesting
twist to do so how
so in other words
the idea would be
for example if you reinforced the 9010
but didn't but but actually provided the
opposite kind of feedback for the 70-30
yeah so in in like the ultimatum game it
wouldn't really make sense but it might
in other contexts kind of
i think
would be interesting to look at if
player b was trying to be strategic
right
yeah and like a big part of this is
we're trying to
make subjects think that these aren't
sophisticated or strategic
um
players that they're watching like
but yeah i mean i think
i think things would get a little bit
more complicated right if you consider
this kind of second order strategy thing
where it's like what what is this person
signaling or trying to get player a to
do
yeah
yeah i think i think there's some
interesting possibilities
these kind of more strategic elements of
these interactions
yeah thanks
uh thanks for a great talk sorry i
missed a few of it and also i'm working
on a project very closely related to of
course schmidt model so i would love to
talk to you offline some more questions
i thought more general question which
i've been thinking about inspired by a
lot of talks uh in this conference is
how do our research on
uh
people's decision making under the
influence of various kinds of norm for
example an equity version here a version
here and how would those research inform
like the ai research in building better
coordination between machine and people
i wonder if you have any thoughts on
that yeah that's a good question i mean
i guess i guess it sort of suggests that
there are things that could be learned
right like if
if you imagine that you don't have a
strong idea of what fairness is
fair or unfair
and and through some process like in
this model
um
just just use the uh basically use the
observational knowledge right to then
get some idea of okay this is what makes
people mad but this is what people
consider unfair
um so but i think i think um i think the
fair schmidt is a sort of
general purpose framework right
at least at least in the in the context
of the illustrator
i think things get much more complicated
to the other paradigm
sorry i didn't see which one you lose
your hands first
um
thanks for the talk it was really
interesting
have you considered
situations with uh
more than two individuals so three
individuals
where you're trying to balance fairness
between three individuals
extending the minigame and uh i'm
guessing i'm just curious of off the top
of your head what kind of complications
would be involved
with that type of extension
yeah get really complicated fast um i
mean hard part of the beauty of the old
native game is that it's
one it's it's almost as simple as it
gets
um and and two right it's kind of
i think
many disciplines sort of agree it's like
a useful operative operationalization of
fairness or unfairness um
so i'm a little i'm a little bit
i get reluctant to try to add more
complications also like
you're
but i think yeah i think
this is a very sort of
simple and maybe impoverished form right
of unfairness but i think maybe what
you're alluding to right is in
situations where there's more parties
there's more sort of complex types
of unfair behavior right that this
this
the ultimatum game right doesn't really
let you
uh operationalize or address
thank you
okay so we'll take this one last
question while uh
guillaume sets up the recording from
natasha
um
when you try to
influence uh a worker's preferences by
having them watch someone else give
preferences what context do you provide
them do you tell them like this is an
expert negotiator or this is a layman so
yeah um sorry
so that um
what what we tried to do is so so that
they're all people on enter um
they think this is just like another
person playing the same game at the same
time so we show them like a fatal turker
id
and we're like these are just regular
people so so i mean maybe the
what you're hinting at is that
people would sort of
uh learn or respond differently if they
thought
they made more
sort of specific assumptions about what
those received motto players were like
like this person's an ephesus
or like this person's in jail or
something
um yeah i think i think that'd be an
interesting twist i mean another kind of
thing we've thought about is
you know what happens if
what we did in chen's experiments is
that it was different players each time
so we're like what what our assumption
is that people are learning some kind of
population level
preference right but but you can imagine
playing with that level of kind of
heterogeneity it's like some of the
people
don't care for example about certain
kinds of certain types of inequity you
know others do
but yeah i'd be happy to hear more
suggestions
all right thanks
all right thanks ross thanks again ross